shucksters chucky episode 5 today
freaking caught up
finally guys why don't you go ahead hit
that like button if you're enjoying
chucky subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction for chucky full-length
watch-alongs for chucky or grab our
chucky patreon page over there we cover
nothing but chucky we're at the same
tier you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch-alongs included for
chucky lastly thank you to nerd chronic
for editing down the highlights for
chucky now let's watch
brooklyn nine-nine
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm not like anybody else
i'll be cut away let's just get into the
good part i know man i want chucky
chucky looks a little different now
honey
they didn't try to get chuckie away from
her
i guess not
after all that
oh no no no oh you've done it
it's gonna be resident evil chucky now
like scrooge mcduck
hey there
um
where's
chucky
i was thinking maybe i could take him to
go get a snickers or something i hate
chucky he's bad jesus lexi it's all
daisies until you dampen the mood
jesus mob
get in there
saw to this you ready to take him down
if he jumps out
it's fine
not that hard to beat chucky if it's
just a one-on-one fistfight guys
oh no
oh i just had to meet cute
why don't you guys get started on the
chapter questions i'll be back in just a
minute
how does it even tell junior
such a great moment
what do we do about junior
no we can't bring him into this
he doesn't have the imagination
yeah give me give me the door
just right there i know
have you guys seen westworld
it's a crazy theme park with these hot
robots and you can like do anything you
want to them i haven't just been a
little busy was the westworld park uh is
this or something
i think to say they have hbo in this
universe
all right who can give me an example of
one of the biotic factors lexi
you guys are not good at this for junior
oh my dudes
close your eyes
what
just do it
okay
[Music]
how long were they staring at each other
that was like 40 minutes
that time lapse
rato is going to make this dump cam
we're ready again in time for the new
year's eve fall it's on the good people
of hackensack
how are the people gonna feel about
their tax dollars paying to clean up our
mess the people of this town need to
know they're safe you're dead yep
i have a surprise for you
close your eyes
oh golly no oh no
[Music]
i made a few phone calls and i joined
the track team
what's she doing texting you
she hasn't returned my text all day okay
phone no
there's your phone on silence
dude yeah
boys give me the phone ass back boy
seriously all right
[Music]
[Music]
jealous chuck
i'd be terrified of that doll was back
yeah you threw it down the garbage can
yeah at the frigging hospital where did
that come from lexi this isn't funny
hasn't your sister been through enough
just get out of my sight go to your room
she doesn't have a room anymore remember
and whose fault is that jesus why would
you leave that doll out of sight
no matter what she's saying follow it
i think we kick his ass till he's dead
hell yeah
then we'll make out
[Laughter]
it's okay
well they got him
right
i can't tell maybe there's a raccoon in
there now
it's got to be
damn it
oh he's already transferred his soul
play the music from office space
what about tommy no i checked totally
cool tommy's just a dumb doll
oh now you've done it
oh guys no
no nothing bad gonna happen today
what do we do now
i don't know you go back to normal i
guess
sometimes i'm not sure what normal feels
like anymore
i feel like that all the time
this is the problem we can solve
together
with our lips
[Music]
[Laughter]
that makes me so happy
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey red
what's new
brad dorf voice voiceover for this guy
yeah
oh
yeah
menage a chuck
oh i started him off guard hello what
the hell you're dead
[Laughter]
boy you really know how to show a girl a
good time
i'm tiffany
i'm charles you should be chucky
what's this
you should be blonde
okay
it's the best adr i've heard all year
i think about logan and the look on his
face when i finally say the words
every time i try to tell them i just
can't
your illness
stage four cancer
oh my god it's not an affair nope
i made a decision i didn't tell them
you spared them
i don't want to go through this alone
no matter how i treat my illness or
what's going on at home
and she's having an affair
both
with the doctor who diagnosed her
oh no
oh god
that's the both of them
let's marry little fella
are you not
jesus christ you're always hungry what
the hell
yep
because love
is strange
[Music]
[Music]
what day is today
what what is the date
no i'm married but i guess i i don't
know why it's been two weeks please
i didn't recognize her
[Laughter]
is there a good guy doll around here
he split his soul into pieces
[Music]
[Laughter]
gets back in there
[Music]
that was weird what's going on
best if we keep the sneaker [ __ ]
between us huh
there goes it'll be our little secret
you're so close yeah call me stead my
mom's not gonna believe that nobody will
believe us
what what did they do
move
jake small chucky was alive and he
killed his dad and he killed oliver and
the cop at the hospital and your
housekeeper too and he wouldn't stop
killing so he broke him into pieces and
now he's dead so everyone can stop
worrying about that if you don't want to
tell me what's going on
fine but
making up stupid [ __ ] like that is just
embarrassing
grow up lexi i told you
good evening everyone i mean that was
the way to handle it
yeah
don't spit it out just point blank that
way i am here to tell you that
hackensack has never been safer we are
still the best hell yeah big little city
in america third you're an idiot
principal mcveigh would like to say a
few words
principal mcveigh
oh his head's cut off
oh no
recognize
oh
no
you look like a tuna belt
no one's gonna love you looking like
this
give me the power i think of you
oh check inator
[Music]
dastardly
[Laughter]
dastardly dull
off off with your head
[Music]
what do you think i am thoroughly
enjoying just the progress of the show i
thought this was a really
fun
tense and and emotional like this was
like the most sort of like touching
episode even though there was a lot of
harsh nasty stuff but this
was the one that dove heavily or the
most heavily
into like letting
just a tender moment play out you know
there were a couple times when this
episode got me a little misty-eyed so uh
that's something new
you know
what did you think okay you missed the
eyed dude that eternals kiss
that's right
i just thought back to the eternals in
that moment i was like brian tyree henry
uh yeah i got mistyad too yeah i don't
know i love the way that they've
built the uh relationship
between the two of them jake and oh my
god i'm blanking on his name what's his
name owen gay good yeah
i don't know i just call him gay kids
devon
yeah jacob but yeah just having that
build up uh has been really
gratifying and has felt again like we've
talked about part of the thing that
makes this show so
uh addictive and so good i think is that
they bother with all that character
stuff whilst also having all the pulp
and
you know chucky mayhem
we've come to expect and yeah like
over so many movies with so many tones
and including characters from past
movies with you know varying tones i
think they do a nice job of
of
orchestrating an overall
sensibility that allows you to shift
between the two
in a very effective kind of way
uh so yeah yeah that's a good point you
know
uh this episode had
how do i say this
i would say that
this particular one
while still really damn good
and while still okay i know how to say
this yes it's still really damn good
and it had some stuff in it that was
some of my favorite from the season so
far
i would say that i wouldn't say this is
the weakest one or worse one because
that would sound like it's a bad thing
i would just say it's my least
favorite one of them all right i don't
mean that in a negative regard i
i guess i just didn't have as much
i wasn't as
wrapped up in it as there are some
things i'm a little bit critical of but
i'm also like well those criticisms are
actually kind of dumb honestly now that
i think about it
but then but for the most part i don't
know it was like the most uh
nothing was really i think what happens
is there's a lot of like surprising
energy or reveals or turns or there's a
lot of unpredictability and here other
than the return of nika
um
that's her name right nika other than
the return of her
i didn't really find much
there was not it was the most like
predictable of how this would all go
down yeah yeah no for sure especially
with yeah chucky transferring his soul
again and the tommy doll and all that
yeah yeah yeah so when i say least
favorite i don't mean that and some for
some people that might be like this
might be their favorite episode and
that's totally cool and uh i'm happy for
you
the fl what'd you think of the
flashbacks
uh
that's where i'm a little bit conflicted
on this particular episode the
flashbacks i'm a little bit uh
i'm a little bit torn on because now
we're riding into the hardcore
the flashbacks in particular have kind
of had this sense of groundedness
towards them
and here it just sort of dwelled a
little bit more into the camp territory
that chucky eventually evolved in that
camp he's always had chickens always had
a sense of camp it's a freaking serial
killer doll like it's it's cartoony by
nature
spells and all sorts of stuff yeah yeah
so i'm not gonna that's where i was like
well it's kind of dumb to say like it's
a little too campy because i like chuck
it's always bad that inherently
uh
you know what it was it was it was
actually the turn of when you find out
that that was actually tiffany yes
because i like the idea when he's like
at the club and he's scouting out people
then he finds a girl who might be able
to match his sadistic ways
and then they lure a girl back and they
just happen to find someone who's more
sadistic
and then i'm gonna kill the blonde girl
instead and then the i think because of
the fact that it was really obvious it
was dub uh and became even more apparent
when it was jennifer tilly yeah who came
in there and started doing the dub
that it started feeling like cheesy and
not in the way that i particularly
uh have gravitated towards i'm not i
don't love that side of it for some
reason but it also works
and i like the color aesthetic and i
love the i love the violent maniacal
glee as always so there's there's a lot
about it that i did like this was just
the first time i found myself
consciously thinking i'm not a there's
some qualities towards the flashbacks
that i don't love as much in this
specific episode yeah
um but that's not i i really don't want
that to overshadow
it's easy it's easy but the reason i'm
being
um
not as blunt or direct with it is
because the last thing i want is for
people to misconstrue that into thinking
i don't like the episode
because if i don't like an episode i'll
tell you guys i don't like an episode
but i feel like no i still really liked
it
and the quality of filmmaking is on par
i love this part with devin and
jake especially i like seeing the way
the relationship's unfolding i love the
lack of self-awareness of how they are
treating junior
junior junior junior should we tell
junior
[ __ ] text each other so that he doesn't
hear us
let's all make sure we've got the text
though right in front of him thank you
guys for having me you guys got no truth
there's no discreetness
at all yeah i just love that moment
which i said we tell junior they just
keep looking at him and walks away like
he's gonna be suspicious as hell if you
guys just you're not even trying to lie
that's the funny part to me is like
you're not even
attempting some some fabricated
storytelling part of my detention to
talk to these two yeah or like you have
kind of doing this stuff medial action
or like you wanted me to apologize to
him and get along with him with your
parents i'm trying to you know like
there's so many other gazillion lies
that she could have told
and it just looks incredibly suspicious
when they're hanging out and
yeah that that part that made me laugh
like that there was i'm like that was a
dumb kid thing but it made me it was so
funny to me that i liked it yeah yeah
and then also i think that carries over
a bit into when she reveals the truth to
him in
in in the way that isn't really gonna
get the truth across you know it's like
they've actually pulled him aside and
tried to communicate which i get is not
exactly what they want to do
um but yeah i'll i'll definitely meet
you partway on the flashbacks because
yeah part of me still appreciates them
because of the weird snuffy sort of tone
that they bring in and you know
it does feel like you are peering into
something again with that more henry
portrait of a serial killer vibe but
yeah the adr
uh and you know it was interesting
because i found i was sitting there
wondering like okay so they must have
cast an actor it looks kind of like brad
duraff and they kind of made him up to
have similar features and stuff so it
was working
for me to that extent okay so i had no
idea about this when we were watching
the episode but apparently fiona durf
actually played the young charles lee
ray like they made her up to be him and
that's very impressive i mean i had no i
thought that was just an actor with
maybe some light prosthetics or
something so like a different you know
just a random guy so like that was yeah
that was
pretty cool despite the tommy wiseau
look
uh uh yeah and then when tiffany's adr
came in
that was a technical element that kind
of started to unravel some of the magic
for me there and also i feel like you
i'm not gonna rest my hat too heavily on
this but i feel like you could have
maybe
prolonged the introduction of tiffany
into the flashbacks a little bit like
you know maybe we see charles lee ray at
this age
you know
for an episode's worth of a flashback in
the next time and maybe start wondering
back because it's been a minute since
i've seen like bride of chucky and all
that and uh thinking like okay so how
does she
first enter into the movies
and you know is this origin also you
know complementary of that or is it more
sort of like forced here and i'd have to
go back and look at it but
i think that might have solved it for me
is just like
it yeah it's that the quick the the the
like
brevity of the events where it's like he
meets this one really kinky chick and
the very next girl he meets is like his
tiffany
and so uh like he just like lucked out
here yeah yeah it's like i might have
wanted and i guess this is kind of uh
you know given the subject matter i feel
almost weird saying it but i could have
maybe used like some kind of build up
whereas like at the end of the flashback
story for this episode is when he
finally comes across her and then maybe
the next bunch of flashbacks is actually
diving into yeah them you know picking
up chicks and killing them and all that
stuff you know that
fleshes out their relationship so yeah
it's like i'm kind of half and half it's
like i i appreciated it here but i think
it could have had a little more oomph
yeah you know this is the first episode
i liked lexi the whole time i know
[Laughter]
just
even her uh inability to lie to junior
properly was still uh it's still amusing
and charming yeah because they were all
i think they were all kind of dumb on
that yeah really
you're devin's mom's a detective like he
of all people has to know how to sneak a
bit yes that would not be the most
obvious possible look at the lap class
she just walks away from him and just
goes like and i and i appreciated the
framing like it was a nice frame that
they had with you know the two boys and
then lexi in the middle but also i just
kept thinking like
if you tilt down junior's just like
looking at you right there he's just
gonna be back there mean mugging you
know
yeah i mean it's it's just an odd image
in general for the for everyone like
everybody knows ordinary everyone knows
that lexi and jake don't get along yeah
just the fact they're hanging out in
public even in a classroom setting like
that draws a lot of attention yeah
looking worried and suspicious and all
that stuff yeah so you'd think it would
have factored in that she's sitting with
them at the auditorium you know
um
but still there was just so much good in
here throughout that is the usual good
that this show has
uh completely delivered on and i i
really enjoy this show a lot like it's
so easy to settle in with it every
episode yeah and i mean i'm glad that
it's funny to me that's that they cast
that guy to be her dad because it
doesn't seem like there's any connection
to cult of chucky but i was glad that he
got like some time to shine in this
episode because he's just kind of been
like i'm supportive dad kind of and in
this one like i as much as the mayor
character is pretty cartoony in terms of
just how
oblivious she is to the people in her
life like he i liked
their back and forth a lot
based off him especially well that's one
thing i really like about this show is
that they take time to develop their
supporting characters
you know i do i really care about
junior's mom all that much not really
but i liked her scene in therapy yeah it
was a good therapy scene it's good
therapy scene it wasn't like cliche
therapy scene it wasn't like about your
mother it wasn't like a richly nuanced
therapy scene for the therapist but for
her to have that reveal i'm wondering
what
how that'll factor into it's by the end
of the season because it's like was
there a reason to
make us think she's having an affair
or just to give us a good mislead yeah
was it just for that purpose just to go
aha she's actually not a bad person
yeah i mean i'm gonna put some trust in
them that maybe they have something
more planned dramatically for that but
well you know what it could be oh my god
i just thought of it i just thought of
it where do you think i'm going with
this chucky's going to voodoo transfer
his soul into the tumor
well no i mean and then his parents
yes and when and when chucky embodies
her
she can walk yeah so maybe she can still
live
through chucky ah yeah
not bad
not a bad cool i'm just wondering what
they're doing with that plot because
it's something they've they've had here
since the first episode yeah it feels
like you would set up a cheating arc to
almost create that sort of like well
she's gonna be part of the body count at
some point but then giving her yeah
something so sympathetic
yeah does not support that so and then
they have like with the junior's dad i
forget what his name is devin sawa
heartthrob from the 90s back in action
what's the character's name
logan
[Laughter]
dad i know all that information
devon saw the heartbreak for the 90.
what's character's name
[ __ ] me
my dad's
brother so much hooky
well what i what i love what they're
doing with his character is when they
first introduce him
you know you have
jake's dad and then you have junior's
dad
and you see just how polar opposite that
they are
one is successful hard working
determined driven
more it seems more positive and then as
these negative experiences been
happening he's slowly morphing into how
his brother is you see how they're cut
from the same cloth yeah even though
they have very different outward
lifestyles the aggressive controlling
manner
yeah
and i i like
the attention is psychology on those two
on that like that's a because he gets
kind of the more we hang out with him
the more scary he kind of gets yeah it's
like you feel like he could snatch
especially when he he
whatever he does he snaps a junior grabs
the phone or whatever i was like oh you
know like you might be way more similar
to uh yeah to jake's dad than we thought
and then like developing lexi's parents
um
watching like i didn't think i really
cared about the dad uh and lexi's side
but i like that how he's always like oh
he has always sort of been like the nice
guy bit of a pushover and she's she's
just very
nah the mom is more
like he wants it more of a traditional
sense of like be a man [ __ ] push me
here she's so
but there are there are a lot of
i have met a lot of people i'm like both
of those parents
and
yeah so yeah the attention to detail
here is very strong
and
albeit a bit predictable but still it's
it's not not like chucky isn't known for
being the the most it's just the series
has been so full of surprises and the
evolution as it keeps going and i'm
still surprised by how much heart it has
like
it's doing things that normally you feel
like
show movies or shows or like we saw
stranger things let's do that
let's get them on the bikes
let's do it but it doesn't
call attention in that way you know it
doesn't feel like a stephen king show
wannabe or something yeah
you know but they are doing the thing of
like it's the teenagers who are the
mystery who are handling the mystery
that the adults are not aware of and
they don't really know how to deal with
all this but it's the kids who are
taking charge and taking care of the
supernatural entity and they know the
truth
uh
and watching the evolution of that
friendship and yes i know watson she
left oh no
send chucky after her for leaving
he is what you get come here buddy
come here
come here and see how many octaves up
you can go come here
come here
come here
he has separation anxiety and his mother
just left for work
and uh
when she leaves every hurry on the
dollar you got to let you know he grows
up
she's going dad mom's god dad
she's never coming back playing with me
she's never coming back
i've abandoned my trunk
every time
oh that notes and this guy thanks so
much for being here what was your
favorite moment
uh leave your thoughts down below
and it's nice to have jennifer tilly
return i wish the credits didn't ruin
that i know they didn't ruin fiona durf
did they that which is funny to me
because i feel like you would probably
caliber them i mean tiffany's got the
longevity but they're both pretty
important i guess not you know
i don't know
because yeah jennifer tilly is the big
surprise you know
but they don't treat her like a big
surprise no which is why i was less
bummed when it actually happened because
i was like oh you know she's a part of
the episode they didn't do it like uh
they didn't emphasize
if anything the the reveal was oh that's
actually tiffany yeah in the flashback
yeah yeah yeah and then when it's the
present day it's like oh [ __ ] stuff's
happening we just we just cut to them
and then we don't even see when they've
like reunited yeah you know
yeah i mean they drove off they go in
the middle of it but yeah but yeah it's
like that scene is is yeah kind of all
to accentuate what's going on with nika
rather than tiffany and so she
she doesn't feel like she's quite
arrived yet even though she's
technically here yeah it's like there's
so
i don't know if i really needed that but
it would have been cool yeah i would
have bought into it like the whole
you know oh
tiffany's entered the frame yeah
but they just kind of cut to oh
apparently they've already caught up and
they're already doing
all right guys subscribe click that like
button and hit that notification bell
and let's do a patreon
anissa oliva you know i really miss you
quite a bit i really do
but i was like we gotta shout her out
here because let's face it
john has this alluring charming presence
looks like oh what a nice guy but really
if anyone matches the look
of young charlie right it's it's gonna
be
shot between two of us
and he's a sick sadistic bastard and
he's gonna need himself a tiffany and
anisa
knowing you you're the only one i can
think of who would voluntarily
to come you know embody that role of
being john's tiffany you guys to go on
so many serial killer rampages together
luring people into your your local motel
inn well actually i know of a guy who
works at hilton hotel so he could
probably get you guys a discount still
might be cheaper going through the motel
in though
but you know like you don't need quality
or luxurious lifestyle to enjoy your
time hanging out with john actually
knowing john he doesn't need to provide
that for any woman they'll still be
there so
my point being is if you're looking for
like a scuzzy dirty
nasty environment the way how john
normally does
you'd be the perfect one to be the
companion for john as he goes on all
those rampages and murders
like that one just now
you died
i'm not
i'm not
gonna yes
[Music]